so thanks everybody for taking the time
out on a sunday morning you know i've
been meaning to do uh one of these
presentations for a while this is just a
you know i'll be covering a few topics
here you know it's just a yeah it's not
i don't want to make this into like some
big sales pitch i just want you guys to
you know look at
different ways
of viewing the order flow that you know
probably you haven't considered before
and hopefully it can make a difference
in your trading
um let me just go over a couple of
things so
it's
the thing with order flow is you know it
allows traders to see things that
other traders just aren't looking at
right you're looking at the volume
that's traded on the bid the volume
that's traded on the offer
and you know its relationship
into you know the overall uh trading in
the market and
what you're going to
learn in this training is a couple of
things you're going to learn the
importance of value in a bar and i'm
going to get into that a little bit
deeper uh shortly and you're going to
learn more about imbalances you know
most traders are familiar with
imbalances and they look at them a
certain way
i'm going to show you a different way
that you can look at imbalances that can
hopefully you know make a difference in
your training because you know at the
end of the day
you know even though you're looking at
information
um you know in the order flow that
nobody else is looking at you also want
to look at it in different ways that
everybody that's looking at the order
flow is
looking at
so you know most of you guys already
know who i am because you're on my list
but you know i've got over 25 years of
professional trading experience you know
trading at investment banks it wasn't
until i started um order flows.com in
2015 that i started working more with
retail traders
and you know it's been a big uh
shift for me because you know before
when i was working in investment banks
you know all the traders there
were all very good whereas when i made
the switch into retail trading you know
trading for myself i consider myself a
retail trader now um you know i started
interacting more and more with traders
that were struggling and
you know i had been training with order
flow before i started up order flows and
i started
um developing my own software to help my
own trading but then when i started
sharing it with other traders they
saw improvements in their trading
and if you're not familiar with it it's
the order flows trader
5.0 just because you know i created it
for to help myself in my own analysis
because you know computers can do a lot
of work for you and the reason that i
bring it up is because
you know the charts that you're going to
be seeing in this presentation are
generated from my order flow software
okay so
i want you to see how easy it is when
you have the proper tools
to
analyze the order flow i mean it doesn't
have to be so difficult that you're
there scratching your head you know
every day looking at the chart trying to
make heads or tails of it really what
you're doing is is you're going to be
looking at
certain things in the order flow you're
going to be looking for
certain occurrences
in
um you know the buying and selling
that's going on so you know before we
jump in just you know
we're all adults here but you know do
understand trading involves risk okay um
because that's just basic
you know some people think that you know
they're going to start trading and get a
lambo um you know in a week it doesn't
work that way
if it did pretty much everybody would be
driving a lamborghini but um so
most trading that
happens is based on what has already
happened in the market okay um and what
i mean by that is you know the way most
people approach the markets is they use
price-based indicators
and
basically they're just looking for
you know a market that's been rising
they'll just buy into it and hope that
it continues to rise what order flow
allows you to do is see where
the you know market moves can stop based
on
the shift in the buying and selling
which if you're just looking at price
isn't going to give you
that
information right because
order flow is based on the premise that
future prices are determined by the
buying and selling pressure currently
happening right now in the market so in
other words order flow trading is about
anticipating future price movements
based on the movements of buy and sell
orders you know that are executed and i
don't just say buy and sell orders in
general
but buy and sell orders that
are executed in the market and
this type of trading can be tricky as it
requires a keen understanding of market
dynamics right you have to understand
what you're looking at you can't just
put up a chart a footprint chart and
think that you're going to get it right
you need someone to
teach you what to look for and you know
and teach you what different things mean
in the order flow
and when it comes to trading
one of the most important things to
remember is to trade in the direction of
the markets okay so in other words when
the market's moving up you want to get
long when the market's moving down you
want to get short and you know the
reason why i talk about this because i'm
going to start i'm going to jump into
the charts in a second here
but when i take trades
right there's a saying i like to let the
market
get me into the trade meaning you know
when
the order flow sets up for buy or for a
cell
i like to see the continuation
continuing in the order flow
all right and that's important because
you know it's easier to make money when
you're trading with the trend than it is
when you're trading against it
right you don't want to be fighting the
trend you want to be
you know the same a trend is your friend
right you want to be trading in the
direction of the trend secondly trading
with the trend ensures that you always
buying low and selling high or vice
versa
selling high and buying low meaning
you know the market is already moving
and you're you're getting in it's like
getting on the elevator
you know you may not be getting on the
first floor you're getting in on the
second floor but you're still getting
out on the eighth floor
so
lastly you know
following the trend i don't even like to
call it the trend i just like following
the order flow it means that you're more
likely to buy into rallies and sell into
dips which are great trading
opportunities right everyone says buy
the dip well
you buy the dip and it keeps dipping you
look like a fool
and
would you rather be doing selling into
the dip as it's dipping or buying into
the dip trying to buy the dip you know
now
you know the whole buy the dip concept
became
mainstream with uh bitcoin that just
seems to keep going up and up and up
regardless
but not all markets do that right the
markets keep dipping dipping dipping
dipping so you know be careful with that
and again so
let the market get you into the trade
now the first thing i want to talk about
is
value okay and one of the most important
concepts for traders to understand is
the relationship between price and value
in general
price is a function of
value
but the relationship between the two is
complex right in a trending or breakout
environment
price leads value
okay
that is price is searching for a level
at which two-sided trading can resume
but if you're in a rotational
environment value is containing price as
it auctions back
from moves away from value now
when you start thinking of value right
you start thinking of market profile and
volume profile
the definition of value and it's worth
70 percent let's say 70 70 of the bar's
volume traded all right so let's take a
look at some charts here um get my
chart up here close that down so you
know most of us
we're familiar with a normal footprint
chart right
let me get a crosshairs going up here
it's not going to help me if it's white
uh crosshairs change it to black
there we go
okay so most of us are familiar with a
footprint chart already right it shows
you know the volume trade on the bid the
volume trade on the offer um you know
delta imbalances
and point of control okay but point of
control
is not the value per se it's more of a
crude
definition of value but it's the only
it's the price level where seventy
percent of the volume
has traded sorry it's the
point of control is
the level where the most volume traded
in a bar okay so if you just add up all
the volume
at each price level right that's your
point of control
but you could take it a step further
okay you can add the value area of a bar
okay so now what you have going on is
you can see where 70 of the value of the
volume rather
it in a bar and you're going to think
well why does that matter
well it's important because
in a bar
knowing where
majority of the volume traded
is going to give you a sense of what
that bar is worth okay think of it like
an item on the grocery shelf what is
what it's worth you know a price of a
candy bar what it's worth
and one bar itself you know may not make
that big a difference but when you start
putting it in context of what's
happening in the market then it's going
to make a difference and
people are going to say well you know
you're looking at a one-minute chart you
know what good is value on a one-minute
chart well you know markets are fractal
right whether you're looking at this is
a one minute chart this is a a
that's also a one-man chart this is a
five-minute chart this is a 15-minute
chart and when you start tracking where
volume is in
you know on different time frames it's
all the same you know the same type of
movements whether it's on a 15-minute
chart
or whether it's on a on a one-minute
chart so
go back to the one-minute chart here
knowing where value is and oftentimes
what you're going to get in bars is
value is going to be overlapping from
bar to bar to bar
right you can see value in this bar is
right here the next bar it's overlapping
next bar is overlapping next bar is
overlapping next bar is overlapping
overlapping overlapping overlapping
overlapping overlapping okay
then it starts to break down as the
market sells off
and
remember right if you're in a rotational
market
the market is just you know when price
gets outside of value it sort of comes
back into value
but if we're in a market where it's
trending
price is going to lead value so
if the market starts trading down you
can see price move down eventually
you're going to see value catch up to it
okay and
why that's important
is because it could give you signs of
when a trend is starting to happen
because you know trends
often happen when markets break out of
periods of consolidation and if you're
in a period of consolidation you know
you want to see value um
you know building up at a certain price
level and again whether you're looking
at a one-minute chart five-minute chart
of 15-minute chart you'd be looking for
the exact same things you know people i
got a question the other day
why do i always make videos with
one-minute charts because that's the
most common chart that traders use in
the market now you know i know traders
use
10 range chart
you know uh
2000 volume chart you know
the whole gamut of charts that you can
imagine people use
and you could still you're still
applying the same ideas
of value whether it's a minute-based
chart a tick based chart a volume based
chart a heiken ashley chart as long as
you can see the footprint on there you
could add the value
so
what you want to look for is when price
starts to move away
from the value okay and not just
value you know the value area itself
right because obviously you know a bar
is going to open and close and it's
going to have the value area the next
bar is going to open
but what you want to be looking for
is
when the market starts to
trend okay and there's easy ways to see
that in the order flow all right so um
just real quick here let's get the right
chart up
what you're going to do right if you're
using the order flows trader software
is we have a feature on there to draw
out
the value area right and we call it
until tested because it's until the
market tests that area again and if
you're using the software it would be
under value area
you would change it here from fixed to
until tested and you just change the box
size from zero because if you have it
fixed it's just going to draw the value
area in the bar itself right with the
box size of zero it's not drawing it out
but if you were to change it
all of a sudden you can draw it out now
you can sort of see it here
um
and just show you the difference in
settings
value area here right you show you shows
until tested it's got to be a box size
more than
two two or more basically
more than one definitely not zero
because you want to draw it out until it
gets tested and
what's gonna what you're to start to see
now
is you're going to start to see
these value areas with
where
it's not touched by the next bar and
oftentimes by the next several bars and
that's going to give you
a clue into a market that's starting to
trend so as you can see here
right you get up here towards the swing
high
you got a value area right it's
overlapping here
the next bar doesn't doesn't even test
it right it's well below its gap down
below so price is starting to move price
is now leading value
okay
and the market starts trending down here
is one this was a
bullish value area right that's the
green
and it just came back in the next bar
but then the next bar came down like
this but you're going to see these areas
like this value area right off the low
of the day
okay
next bar well above it right price is
leading value price is leading value
away
obviously you got a gap
between the two value areas this this
box here is the value area this next bar
the box is the value area now of course
you're not going to know where the value
area you know whether it's untouched
until the next bar closes right because
the next bar could open up trade around
in here and come back down and test it
before the close
wait for the next bar to
settle so you you're confirmed that the
value area is away from it
you can see you got a nice move up here
now people are going to say well yeah
you had one here okay well
the market had already been trending
down
right and then you get the value area
out there that's not how you want to
take it you know you got to take um what
you're seeing in the order flow and use
your general knowledge of the market
right you just had
if
right if you're getting a value area
that's untouched right here at you know
4506 4504
after the market you know has been
trading down into new lows that's not
you know you probably don't really want
to sell that i'd prefer to
look for reasons to be buying after you
made a new low that's what this red line
is
and i'm getting it right here
because while the market can keep going
lower it did
but
you know it's only going lower by
you know two or three points you know
i'd rather get um you know 10 or 20
points on the way up
um
you know here we got you know this
market rallied up a little bit then
you're starting to see the
value areas right that aren't being
tested right price is now starting to
lead the way away
right you see the value area even though
it gapped up here you got overlap
overlap overlap overlap overlap overlap
kissing the top here overlap overlap a
little gap up now it gaps down now you
got that value area exposed
and the market drops down
all right
you hit the new low here
all right again where would you rather
be getting short off of this value area
here or off of this one right you know
as you're making new lows
you know it depends you know i guess it
depends on the type of trader you are me
i'm not always big on selling into new
lows but
you know some guys that you know they
love to sell into new lows that really
just depends on you
me i like to have reasons to be buying
off of lowes
and
if i get something like this i get this
value area that's
hasn't been touched in the next bar it
not just
touch i mean it's not overlapping
obviously but price doesn't even trade
back into it
right just like here price doesn't even
trade back into that value that's why
that you're drawing out this value area
zone
all right and you see you got that
little move up you know from the
you know i don't know what that is 07
ish area all the way up to about you
know 12
13 14.
and you know you could just go through
them
you can see them you know all the time
now when a bar is like this this is a
doji candle where the bar opened and
closed at the same price that's why it's
gray so if it was bearish it would be a
red color if it was bullish it would be
a green or a blue right here's a nice
one right we got nice overlapping
value areas it looked like it was going
to break down here but then it traded
right back up into this value area that
we had been in
next bar comes down doesn't even trade
back into it again another bar doesn't
trade back into it
and it just makes this nice move down
from you know this 27 ish area down into
the 17 area and
earlier
i have
talked about right just a few minutes
ago i talked about letting the market
get you in
so let me expand on that a bit here
when i say let the market get you in
right so now i have a potential cell
here okay
in this bar once this bar closes down
closes
it starts trading below this is a
bearish value area in the sense that um
we haven't gone back into that value
area
now we're below it the bar closed okay i
know where the low of this bar is here
at 27 and a half i'd be looking to get
short
you know anywhere in here around you
know 27
um to 27.5 anywhere around the low of
this bar right i don't want to be um
you know getting long getting short if
this bar starts trading back up in you
know all the way up in here right you
want to let the market confirm that it's
trading down so
know you want to be lower than the low
of the signal bar
okay that's why when i said you know
short around 27
for the move down that's the area that
you'd be looking to be getting short as
long as it's trading around 27 yeah
that's your sign to be getting short
so here was a little buy
okay so you'd be getting along somewhere
around you know twenty
three
three quarters
somewhere in there
um you know it was a move up throughout
the 26 27 area so not a big gigantic
move but
again
it's not just about getting the signal
from the order flow and thinking that
the trade is going to go to infinity you
still got to trade right you still got
to read what's happening in the order
flow and when you get up into this bar
you're starting to see some bearish
activity
you're starting to see market weakness
um you're starting to see a bearish
prominent point of control obviously the
market reversed here
closed lower
and then just sort of going sideways so
you know you still have you're still
responsible for reading what's happening
in the market
all right another long here's another
short and like i said you know markets
are fractal this is a five minute chart
okay
right here's your
this area here right you got your
bearish
value area right you'll notice how it
trades right back up into that value
area and falls down when you start
looking at longer term charts
you start to see
the market often come back into those
levels
um you know to act as support and
resistance
but on a shorter time frame charts like
minute-based charts to me it's just a
go with trade
but again you know you could i know a
lot of guys that use this software and
they're looking for the pullback into
there
to get short you know but the problem is
sometimes on longer term charts you're
gonna get a big zone you know this is 37
down to
32 basically so that's five point zone
and you know if you're getting short you
know right at the edge of it at 32
you know your stops up here at 37. for
some of you guys that's a five point
stop that might be too much
but again it depends on on how you're
trading you know but you could scale in
in here
as well if you're trading back you know
the pullbacks right sometimes the
pullbacks work like this one did
sometimes market pulls back to a level
and just keeps selling off so there's
different ways to trade it
but again you know this is a five minute
chart
right you're seeing a nice move up you
know this is the evening session some so
you're getting smaller moves this was on
the evening going into non-farm payroll
so it's pretty quiet that night
um but if you look back on the day
before
right you had your
zone here
okay
then it just sort of went sideways then
it started breaking down and then you
got your exposed zone in here you're
getting short around the 64-ish area you
know for a nice move down
now this is
a bullish
value area
but you'll notice the market is below it
you don't want to be
getting into the thought of well there's
this an exposed value where you're going
to get longer i get short
no it doesn't work that way right if
it's a bullish one you want to be up
trading above the value area just as if
it's a bearish value area like this one
you want to be trading below it
right you want to be trading below it
you don't want to have a red zone being
drawn out and you're trading you know
above that red zone see if i could find
a
example um
not really
you've seen some
you know you don't see any
um i don't i don't have an example of
the red zone where you're trading above
it but um now you get the idea right you
want to be trading in the direction
the value is moving and again
if the market is trending price is going
to lead value
so
if you're on a 15-minute chart okay
you're not going to get as many
but you know you're going gonna see a
feeling happening in here these red
zones
get this crosshair up
the black right you're trading below the
value area
right here's a doji bar
the market starts trading below that was
on thursday
you get another doji bar another red bar
right the zones being drawn out once
these bars close and they close below
that's your sign to be getting short
right there's a nice one here again
these are 15 minute charts you know
whether you're looking at a 15-minute
chart a one-minute chart you're looking
at the same things
all right there's a nice one here this
one is a small one here
actually this one
if you're getting long hair came all the
way back down tested that low tested
that value area and then made a
half-hearted move up
now this was one going into late on
tuesday
right up there again it's a 15 minute
chart this one here
yeah we traded up came back into that
zone and then rallied up
now again it's
it's
it's funny because you know someone just
asked a question i don't understand this
well
it's
you have to understand
value
right it's
if you don't know if you're not familiar
with market profile or volume profile
what volume profile is you're looking at
where vault where
the volume trades right whether it's in
a bar you know if you're looking at the
volume profile right it's going to show
up on the side of a bar if you're using
market profile you're looking at a 30
you're looking at the value for a 30
minute period what i'm saying is you
take it down on a smaller time frame um
you know you're taking it down on
you know a 15 minute or a five minute or
even a one minute chart
and you're looking for these value areas
you know edward as you know any help
from delta yeah you can
apply delta
to it now when you when you're looking
at
let's go back to the one-minute chart
here
okay so
when you're looking at
delta
in the order flow right you don't always
just want to take the delta in the bar
okay because
again
oftentimes on red candles it's going to
be down
negative delta on green candles is going
to be up you sort of want to be taking
it in context of what's happening
in the several bars before it
okay
so like for example here okay you gotta
buy here and you gotta sell here right
with the value areas the zones being
drawn out
and
okay it went from you know negative
delta on the low
to a
positive delta to a more positive delta
okay that's fine
um
and then as you start seeing it shifting
again
when you're training with order flow
it's not like you get into the trade
it's like this for any method of
training it's not like you just get into
the trade and
you set your atm to go off you know with
your your stop and take profit
then expect you know that's the end of
it right no you still should be watching
what's happening in the order flow and
you know if you're long off of this
zone here
but you see the order flows start to
turn negative
then get more negative you know it's
gone from 411 which is a decent number a
delta right to 201
to just minus 102 okay
it's weakening right it's getting weaker
it's not getting stronger you're long
but
also now you're seeing aggressive
sellers come coming in you're seeing the
aggressive buying
weakening in the sense that it's not
getting stronger right it's going here
went from 68 to 411. then it went to 201
okay it's still positive but you know
not as strong as 400 you're going to
move away from the low
you you know you're going to want to
ideally do it in dramatic fashion in the
sense that you're going to have a nice
positive delta but it's just you know
it's a small delta it's just 201
again it's not negative but it's not the
end of the world
but then you see this next bar here this
red candle with the negative delta okay
that's not a good sign
and then obviously this next bar comes
in with a stronger negative delta so if
you're long from here and your stop is
somewhere you know below the the low of
this bar definitely below the low this
value area that's your time to get out
right and then once you see this bar
come in
and then you've got this value area
being drawn out and you see the value
area is obviously lower than the
previous two value areas you're starting
to think of what's happening
okay
so if you're going to use delta right
use it sort of in
connection with
what else is happening in the markets
right you know here we are at the low of
the day
you got the nice strong negative delta
then positive delta
it draws out
no the value area hasn't been touched in
the next bar it's got a nice positive
delta 638 then it just sort of goes
sideways on you 92 negative negative 262
50 uh negative 70 then it starts
building up again but still holding up
you know above that area
obviously this one here
again you're coming up off your low
you're getting some deltas building up
122 259 272 hey that's great that's what
you like to see comes back into this bar
right this green sorry this red candle
opens up you trade all the way into that
zone
minus 60 delta okay it's not the end of
the world market does rally back up
closes you know it's still a red candle
but it closes somewhere you know towards
the high end of the candle
okay
then this bar you get a nice
move higher a little bit i'll say nice
move by about you know point and a half
higher than this high of this bar
but then it turns around closes down now
you're seeing some things here in the
order flow sequencing that's what this
is this is a bearish point of control
it's got a positive delta
and then this bar trades all right you
got a negative delta 241. so you couple
what you're seeing in this bar with the
sequencing that's what this purple is
this bar here with the sequencing
obviously the bearish
point of control here that's why it's
red the negative delta okay and you're
still trading you know somewhere you
haven't hit your stop because your stop
would be somewhere down in here
around 28.
and you're trading 29 okay you have an
opportunity to get out in here around 29
take a smaller loss than getting fully
stopped out
so you know that's how you can use delta
um
in there
uh rob asks um
how can you determine the trend well you
watch the value okay
simply
obviously you're seeing bars you know
green bars red bars but what's the
values areas in the bars doing is is it
migrating lower or not not just the
point of controls
right because here right you see point
of control
higher higher so you got one two three
two and three are both higher
then
red comes i then this red candle comes
in point of control is below obviously
these three bars which is bearish
but then you're starting to see this but
this value area this is the value here
from here to here this is the value here
from here to here they're overlapping
right one two three four five six
now you get that gap in value between
this bar and this bar right so
naturally you should be thinking okay
this market can start to
move lower now if this bar was a little
bit lower right if it didn't trade back
up into this value then it would have
that zone drawn out but the simple way
to determine you know the trend of a
market is watch what's happening
with the values in the bars are they
moving
up or down
right if they're overlapping that's just
something going sideways that's why even
though these points of controls are
moving higher you know it's not
anything to really get you too excited
right because the value areas are still
overlapping you want to be looking for
you know gaps in the value area because
again price is going to lead value in a
trending markets
uh pepe yes yeah this is on a footprint
chart this is from the order flows
trader software chart
okay so the next thing i want to talk
about
is imbalances in a bar
okay and you know we all familiar with
what imbalances are right it's it occurs
in the bar
when
you know you have
more aggressive
buyers than aggressive sellers or vice
versa more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers and
really what you're looking for with
imbalances is when there are more
aggressive traders in a particular
direction that's what's going to create
that imbalance right and generally
you're expecting prices to move in that
direction but imbalances sometimes in
the order flow can lead to trading
activity drying up altogether right the
trapped traders right everybody talks
about trapped traders as being this this
big market moving
um phenomenon and you know in all
honesty really what trap traders is more
of a signal of is trading activity
drying up all right more than than
anything because often times you know
people say oh you know traders are
trapped but the amount of traders that
are trapped is so insignificant it's not
going to
cause their
um
it's not going to cause the
market to reverse
or anything like that you know they're
they're buying at highs
and getting out is not going to cause
the market to reverse
it's
you know basically
you know people that got in late to the
party and are long and wrong or short in
the hole
so as a result all right again this is
the important part imbalances in order
flow
again this is where it differs for
the sort of the norm imbalances overflow
could lead to training activity drying
up altogether in that direction
okay so it's important for traders to
be aware of imbalances and overflow so
they can see how they impact the market
and what i want to talk about today is
is inverse imbalances um pepe yeah it
can i don't have data for the ftse 100
from the
life exchange but
it definitely can be used on ftse
so let's go back to the charts here so
uh
one minute okay so
right imbalances
now we're all familiar with what
imbalances are right you see inside the
candlestick right inside the footprint
you're seeing red numbers or
black numbers
and
you've also seen blue numbers okay so
the black numbers in the footprint are
just your normal order flow right
there's no imbalance there but if you're
seeing a red number
uh where's the red number here 37
against two in this two-way auction in
this bid offer
you have more aggressive selling than
aggressive buying only two lots were
bought
aggressively 37 were aggressively sold
so that's an imbalance and you determine
that by
um
you know a certain ratio that you want
to use you know most people use four to
one which is fine um it's sort of like
the industry standard if there was one
in trading you know or everyone's got
their own opinion on stuff but
most people use at least four to one
again i know people that use smaller
numbers i know people that use three to
one i know people that use five to one i
know people that use
um higher numbers nine to one
but when it comes to
imbalances right we're familiar with
what stacked and balances are right yes
this is a stacked imbalance right this 5
14 13 this is a stacked imbalance and
they make for some great trading
opportunities okay but you know everyone
is familiar with what a stacked
imbalance is and what a normal imbalance
is whether it's a buying and balance or
selling a balance
but what i want to talk about today is
this this thing called inverse imbalance
and if you're using the order of
illustrator software
um
let me just
get show you guys here it's under um
volume imbalance all the stuff is
alphabet alphabetical
but you can see it here display inverse
imbalance okay
right up here it's checked now
you can see the imbalance trigger in
percent is set to 400 that's four to one
that's 400 percent
and what i'm doing on this one is i'm
sending it to two so i'm looking for a
stacked imbalance
that's inverse of what you normally
expect
um but it's only got to be two and let
me just
show you what i'm talking about here so
uh where am i here
uh
okay let me find it
you know some days you get none other
days you get a lot so
this is what i'm talking about here
it's an inverse imbalance so you got 2
against 73 0 against 46 right so you
have this blue zone drawn out this is a
selling imbalance but it's a selling
imbalance in a green candle and you know
sort of going back to delta right you
got a negative delta right negative 88
on a green candle normally
you're going to expect to see green
candles have positive delta right and
you're going to expect red candles to
have negative delta now
how can a market go up on negative delta
right because
aren't aggressive sellers in control of
the bar
right because you got the negative delta
well the reason why the delta
often is negative is because you have
what's called supportive volume
let me drink some water here
and excuse me supportive volume that's
better
is
definitely you know by definition it's
going to support the market right so you
can see you got negative 88 delta why is
because you have these selling
imbalances right you have people that
were bidding the market
or absorbing rather the aggressive
selling that was going on now this bar
here right you got negative 59.
this is not imbalance 192 against 118
but i could see
clearly you know why you got the
negative delta but sometimes it just
stands out so obvious
in the order flow right with what we
call an inverse imbalances when you have
stacked
imbalances
of absorption okay so
you can see here right the 73 against
two 46 against zero this is what we call
an inverse imbalance
and again let the market take you in let
the market start trading higher okay and
it starts trading higher here eventually
it worked its way up here
this is a inverse imbalance now this is
a bearish one that's why it's drawn red
this one failed
all right but it's
you know 104 here
74 here it's a 25 against 104. it's 11
against 74.
okay now you do have negative delta of
minus 92
so obviously there was more aggressive
selling happening in this bar
now people say well can you
use that delta you know sort of as
confirmation take that inverse and
balance as long as you got positive
delta
um you could but um you know just watch
what's happening in the order flow as
well i don't like to just you know sort
of sometimes you know we like to
automate things that just make it
brainless for
us as traders but you know i think you
know the best
thing we can do as traders is you know
still analyze the market now this is one
this is like at 5 30 in the evening
after the reopen
but again it doesn't go anywhere just go
sideways right let the market take you
in if this was going to really rally off
this you'd be looking for this next bar
to at least trade higher doesn't even
take out the high of the bar with the
inverse of balance
uh but let me just
get you on to some more here
again same thing it doesn't go anywhere
it doesn't go any higher than the signal
bar
eventually it does but by that time it's
too late
for me i like to let the market start
moving in that direction within the next
you know the next bar basically next two
bars rather
again it's not something that happens
all the time or very often some days
you're going to get none
some days you might get two or three
all right so here's one here right mark
is just coming down in here right you
got the negative delta you got the green
candle so there's some absorption
happening in here right at this level
the 260 against 42 the 143 against 10
the 29 against zero the next bar opens
up it's basically trading inside makes a
new low and then the next bar starts
trading higher how do you trade that
well you got your inverse imbalance here
you know the high of this bar is here
right we just we closed this bar just
right off off the high
is you know 91 you're just dropping a
buy stop up here at 91 and a half
right it moves from 91 and a half all
the way up into the 95 96 97 area that
more or less goes sideways you know 95
is a nice exit
again it's not how most people would
look at imbalances right here you got a
nice
inverse imbalance right you got this
nice green candle with big negative
delta minus 1100 but the next bar
doesn't go any higher
right it doesn't even take out the high
of that bar right we close this bar at
76 and a half next bar opens up and 76
and a half immediately trades it down
right it's not just about saying oh i
got an inverse imbalance here i got to
just get long automatically no
let the market take you into the trade
so that that's a trade that you know you
wouldn't be you wouldn't be taking
but you identified it as a potential
trade right the one back here
yeah you would have
you would have taken right because you
got the follow-through order flow two
bars later
so it's all about watching what's
happening
in the order flow right you have
something that's actionable that makes
sense that you can understand and then
you just you trade with it in that
direction
okay well you probably want to take this
this happened
at 3 51 in the afternoon but the market
started going down then it closed
for an hour then reopen but
most of us were done trading by the cash
close
and this is i don't know this is 31st
into friday
you know here's one it's a small move
they started trading higher just
again this was at 1 50 in the morning on
non-farm payroll day so you're not
expecting much movement
so it just it just inched higher and
went sideways and came down now again
here right this is a bullish inverse
imbalance but what's happening
is you're trading below it right that's
not a trade you want to take if it's a
bullish signal right if it was a
blue bar being drawn out you're
expecting the market to be trading above
it if it's trading below it
definitely you're not taking it simple
right because you know this market
this bar the high of this bar is what 49
okay so your buy stop to get into the
trade is at nine and a half
it doesn't go there it's not taking the
trade
now
okay
now here's one
this was you know this was on the number
730 and
again i don't know if you'd want to be
trading on the number but you know this
one it did happen
i mean nowadays you get these numbers
there's just so much other
stuff happening in the market you
probably don't want to take it now this
was an inverse imbalance this was a buy
one but again similar right we're below
it
okay we're trading below all right this
is a bullish one you want to be trading
above
you can't even close above this bar
doesn't even close above it so that's
not a good um valid signal right this
was a bullish sorry this was a bearish
one this one okay he got stopped out on
let's see you know here's a nice bullish
one
again we're trading above it okay fine
the highest bar is 28. you know you're
getting long 28 and a half okay along
with 20 and a half trades right back
into that area and then
immediately rallies up into you know 36
ish area where it just starts to go
sideways
and this was a bullish one but again
we're going into the cash close now this
is e-minis right and
i know not everybody trades e-minis all
right a lot of people like to trade mnq
or nasdaq or ym and if you're trading ym
right with the same settings obviously a
more volatile market you can't trade the
same as a market that's less volatile
right so you can't kind of trade
if you're trading um
mini dao
right with a stacked imbalance size of
two
you're going to see a lot of them
right like this one here you know here
here
you're just gonna you know and it's
gonna be pointless because
the market is so
choppy in the sense of not just market
but each bar is choppy where you're
getting a lot of price especially now
with everything going on in eastern
europe you know getting a lot of bars
that got zeros in them
okay so it's not going to be very
effective so what you're probably going
to want to do is adjust it from
here
from two a stacked
inverse and balance level of two
to three
okay because now you're you know
basically you're just adding
um an extra level in there
and
you know you're going to see more
clearer signals right this is a nice one
that's coming in
right here right
this is you know move from about 660
up above 700
right because if you're just looking at
two levels
you're going to get
a lot of them and that's probably not
going to be very
useful to you because it's i don't say
it's noise but
it's too what do you want what's the
term uh because
it's too um
i'm a lost word right now it's too light
in the sense that you're gonna get a lot
of them because the threshold is set so
lower but when you start raising the
threshold
you know you're going to get fewer of
them right this is one that didn't work
right this looked like it was going to
sell off and it just sort of hung around
went sideways and then rallied
okay again you know that happens
and
you know you just want to be taking
trades that have a higher chance of
working out right so you had one nice
winner
and one you know small loser
on the
mini dow
on the ym let's see if there's any more
this is the day before right this is
another one right here okay so this
one's actually four levels
right and you're talking about a move
going into the lows you know 24 the low
for the day is 8.96
you know that's about 30 point move
right there that you're looking for at
least test the lows and here test the
lows and make new lows
but again you know it's coming in off
the low if it was coming in right here
right at the low of the day you know i'd
be a little bit more hesitant
but
you know markets love to test levels
test highs and test lows so i'm not too
concerned as long as we're
far enough away from the the higher the
low
here is one all right you got that
inverse imbalance kick off right there
and again the bar closes right here
at 41 you just drop in the cell stop you
know 39ish area
you know it goes from 39 to the next two
bars trades all the way from 39
down to 08 right then it sort of goes
sideways
but
again you know it it's all about
understanding your market right for
e-minis you could use
an inverse
imbalance level of two
whereas on
mini dao
two is not going to be effective at all
again you wouldn't take this one this
one's at
you know 3 49 3 50 in the afternoon you
only got 10 more minutes before
cme shuts down
but again it's not something you're
going to get a lot of but you know you
should be on the lookout for them you
know because when they happen
it could result in some decent trades
you know this was at five in the morning
um
yeah was it a move
small one
this is the you know and again
you could draw out these zones until
fixed or you know i like to keep them
fixed for inverse imbalances because
if it's not really paying off
after
you know four or five bars that this has
drawn out four five bars so the signal
bar is one two three four five if it's
just hanging around there like this you
just cut it and wait for the next one
but again an inverse imbalance differs
than a regular imbalance in the sense
that you know they may not happen every
day regular imbalances you're going to
get them every day this is a nice one
here you're just some bar closes here
you're just dropping a buy stop right
here
high is 70 you just drop in a buy stop
around 72.
you know it trades all the way up to
you know
120s
almost in the next two bars it's already
trading 15. so you know if you're long
from 72
you know
i don't know it's a quick 30 ticks but
you know maybe you can hold it out for a
bit more
you know this was one it just started
just it just came in and stopped you out
unfortunately
but again you can see with inverse
imbalances right it's
not as often as you would like to see
them but um you know when they come they
can result in some very nice trades you
know here's one that just started
working out but then again it's just
sort of hanging around there hanging
around your entry point for
five bars that's why we draw this out
a certain amount of bars
i've just found that
if the move doesn't happen
quickly
it's probably not going to happen it
might happen eventually or it may go up
here and stop you out
you know that's the decision you have to
make as a trader right you still gotta
trade i'd rather get out at a smaller
loss than
um you know sort of tie myself up into a
trade i'd rather be able to
get out of the trade be done with it
and you know just wait for the next
trade to happen
all right this was one started to make
that move but again you know if you're
dropping your sell stop in here on 57 58
you know it's a move down into well the
low is 37.39
but you know hopefully you can see
um you know a different way of looking
at imbalances rather than just the plain
normal
um imbalances i don't have time to go
through every single market and explain
all this but this one you know i
wouldn't take
because it didn't go any lower
eventually it sort of sold off a little
bit but again you know you're looking
for the market to move after
within two bars more or less
again this one it just went one
tick higher here
so you know that one wouldn't have got
you into it
um
you know sometimes you know people ask
me hey you know if if there's a trade
like this and it doesn't go should i
should i get short i i
wouldn't advise that that's not how i
would normally trade a market
you know or a cycle i get a signal and
it's not working no should i go the
opposite
[Music]
probably not
but um but anyway as you can see like on
the mini dial when you go back in time
it's not a lot just you know it's